>> Greg: IN CASE YOU MISSED
THE OPENING, THE DOOR HIT ME IN
THE HEAD TO.
I HAVE A BIG BUMP ON MY HEAD.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA RESEARCH
CENTER.
THE EVENING NEWS COVERED THE
WOMEN'S MARCH THREE TIMES MORE
THAN THE MARCH FOR LIFE.
CAN YOU BLAME THE NEWS?
THEY AREN'T AS COOL AS
CELEBRITIES.
>> WE HAVE A RACIST IN THE
OUR ABILITY TO GET PEOPLE THE
FACTS.
>> WHITE WOMEN NEED TO HOLD UP
OUR END OF THE FIGHT, NOT JUST
COMING TO RALLIES WITH
LIKE-MINDED OTHERS.
>> Greg: WE HEARD THEM LOUD
AND CLEAR.
THEY ARE -- WE HAVE HEARD THE
MEDIA COVERAGE STORY BEFORE THAT
THE MEDIA COVERS X MORE THAN Y.
IT'S AN OLD STORY.
THE QUESTION IS WHY IS IT TRUE?
EVEN IF A NETWORK PRODUCER
WANTED TO COVER THE PRO-LIFE
MARCH MORE, IT'S RISKY.
BY TOUCHING IT IN A MEETING, YOU
GIVE YOURSELF A WAY THAT YOU
MIGHT NOT BE A LIBERAL.
RATHER THAN EXPOSE YOURSELF
RATHER THAN EXPOSE YOURSELF, YOU
BITE YOUR LIP.
WE HAVE ALL BEEN THERE AT
FALSIFICATION WHERE YOUR PUBLIC
WEARING AN UGLY SHIRT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THE ONE
TELLING THEM IT SUCKS.
A BETTER EXAMPLE, WHEN YOUR MOST
POMPOUS TALENT, JOE SCARBOROUGH,
THINKS HE IS A POP STAR.
>> WE GO TO BREAK WITH SOME OF
WEEKEND AS MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
GATHERED IN CITIES AND STREETS
ACROSS THE NATION FOR THE 2018
WOMEN'S MARCH.
♪ ♪
>> WHAT THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING
IS SO WRONG.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
TEN TIMES WORSE THAN NICKELBACK.
>> Jesse: I LIKE NICKELBACK.
>> Kimberly: SO DO I.
PREFERENCE FALSIFICATION.
AS LONG AS THOSE AROUND JOE
DON'T TELL HIM HOW BAD HE IS, HE
WILL REPEAT SUCH DESPERATION.
MUCH TO THE AMUSEMENT OF PEOPLE
LIKE ME.
KEEP TELLING JOE THIS IS GREAT
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO LAUGH MY
ASS OFF.
TO LIVE, THE PRODUCER THINKS
SOMETHING.
A >> Dana: THEY ROLL THEIR
EYES.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO SHOW THAT?
>> Greg: NO CELEBRITIES AT
MARCH FOR LIFE.
>> Dana: ONE THING ABOUT MARCH
FOR LIFE, THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
COME TO THE MARCH BUT THEY DON'T
JUST DO MARCH FOR LIFE ONCE A
YEAR.
THEY LIVE THIS EVERY DAY.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE ISSUE AND
THEY ARE HAVING IMPACTS AND
MAKING A BIG DIFFERENCE.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY FROM A NEWS
PERSPECTIVE AND FROM A VIDEO
PERSPECTIVE YOU WANT TO COVER
THESE MARCHES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY WERE BIG AND THEY
WERE IN THE MAJOR CITIES AND
BECAUSE IT IS SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO GET RATINGS FOR
IT.
I THINK THAT'S WHY IT HAPPENS.
>> Greg: FAIR POINT.
JESSE, DO YOU PLAN ON RELEASING
A SONG ANYTIME SOON.
BAD.
>> Greg: YOU LIKE NICKELBACK.
>> Kimberly: YOU DON'T LIKE
ANYBODY.
>> Greg: I JUST LIKE GOOD
MUSIC.
>> Jesse: I WOULDN'T CALL YOUR
BUMP INS GOOD.
I THINK WHAT THEY DO --
I THINK WHAT THEY DO -- THE
MEDIA COVERS THE CONSERVATIVE
RALLIES AND LIBERAL RALLIES
DIFFERENTLY.
IF IT'S A CONSERVATIVE RALLY,
TEA PARTY OR MARCH FOR LIFE OR
SOMETHING, THEY IGNORE IT IF
IT'S THE MARCH FOR LIFE OR IF
IT'S THE TEA PARTY, THE
INFILTRATED AND ONLY SHOW THE
MOST OFFENSIVE AND DANGEROUS
SIGNS AND TRY TO INTERVIEW THE
IT'S AN OCCUPY WALL STREET MARCH
OR ANTI-       ANTI-ANTIFA RALLY
OR ANTI-       ANTI-ANTIFA RALL,
OR ANTI-       ANTI-ANTIFA RALLT
OR ANTI-       ANTI-ANTIFA RALLE
OR ANTI-       ANTI-ANTIFA RALLY
LIONIZE THINGS.
THERE IS NO INTEREST GOING INTO
THE GUTS OF THE WOMEN'S MARCH
AND EXPOSING THOSE NASTY SIGNS
THE WOMEN'S MARCH ON SATURDAY
BECAUSE I HAD TO GO LIVE BECAUSE
OF THE SCHUMER SHUTDOWN.
THERE WERE PEOPLE FLIPPING THE
BIRD AT FOX NEWS, HURLING REALLY
THERE'S A TOTAL DIVERSITY --
>> Kimberly: I THINK YOUR
SWELLING IS GOING DOWN.
>> Greg: THE PEOPLE ON TWITTER
WILL BE THE JUDGE OF THAT.
>> Kimberly: PREDICTABLE
OUTCOME.
I THINK IT IS SUCH A GOOD POINTS
THIS IS A CALLING WHERE EVERY
DAY THEY WAKE UP AND THEY ARE
THINKING ABOUT IT AND THEY ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT A SHOW OF
FORCE FOR ONE DAY.
IT'S A LIFETIME CHOICE.
A MISSION THEY ARE COMMITTED TO
WHICH I THINK IS VERY NOBLE.
THEY ARE CONSISTENT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO PURSUE IT.
IN TERMS OF THE WOMEN'S MARCH, I
LIKE WOMEN.
EVERYBODY LIKES WOMEN.
WE ARE FOR EQUALITY, EQUAL PAY,
JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
PEOPLE NOT BEING DISPARAGED OR
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON NOW.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO USE THEIR
VOICE.
I'M REALLY FOR IT BUT I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD PICK
UP YOUR SIGNS.
IT'S DISCOURTEOUS TO LITTER.
>> Greg: IT WOULD BE NICE IF
THEY INCORPORATED OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD WHERE WOMEN ARE TRULY,
TRULY BEING HARASSED AND BEATEN.
FOR SIMPLE THINGS AND ADULTERY
THIS EVIL, SEXIST REGIME.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> Juan: I THINK THAT WAS
LARGELY AN ANTI-TRUMP RALLY.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
THAT'S MY POINT.
THAT'S WHAT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CALLED.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S WHAT
IT WAS.
>> Greg: DON'T CALL IT A
WOMEN'S MARCH.
COLLEGE IN ANTI-TRUMP RALLY.
PRO-CHOICE MARCH, THE NUMBERS
ARE UNBELIEVABLE, HUGE.
THE MEDIA WILL STILL GIVE TIME
TO PEOPLE WHO FEEL THAT ABORTION
IS WRONG AND A CRIME AGAINST
HUMANITY EVEN AS THEY TALK ABOUT
IT.
THEY DON'T SAY THIS WAS A
SMALLER MARCH.
THEY GIVE EQUAL TIME.